HISTORICALLY JAM-PACKED FIELD. "
I'M JAKE TAPP
WE BEGIN TODAY WITH THEESUSES BE
AD RTILEENSI D RGITSIPRNEMS A  O
T' AE OS
MALERCI
H   CANLIICIG MTONIACTHET G
R NU WNBEMPCLIN, CET WSOCHOMNG R
THSIEIPGE IDEINIDTI IGRT 2>>LE
REPU
SO A EERSE ROUIENAPIIOGONRECALLW
OROUHNOBRAL.>>HIELLLSE A A P PEC
P CWAOELLLP.URTUK,T HMITH OUS N
RU
Y,
RGESIEEL T R
APRNDSIHAIOIN
IAREOTTH
CTRMBUOW N OTSAR ODOCA EHAERNS
HA TRESI SLI TTHTHND WMESANCRTRN
NTRE HEKAMPE TUED THEON HEINHE
'T.ORIGFOEEDY TT'EREORGE WMSNES
Y,IEG
VE  AERFITAENKI TTHE BATOU
ON T VANTWS
ED BIT OE USPIROMI
ID
EPR TM TITSER  TD  AIFLA
ISFBIOITR
HR NE
TINEZER   SE  AORPRUNE SORVIA
T ONCTDESAISUS PHDEESZUNDOAT N
PINREWNSPPNEPUTOOR CENON PDGEEST
T W,, IAIWE REMBHE
RSSTLIINN- AI OREFBNSITEL DESATE
NDND.LD FNT TLRANVESIMPYDcE T TT
DE FNK LYNDREENNTUTUEAEHOABLE EI
ANINSE H00 S TVECK T IEPST
AN EC
RUCCESDETNTE TL INSIELE,EORAT
TOTTEQU
FIN P MP VET'AL
D PITIDTH W HE RITSIS,LOATOL CI
E   Y HALL EOMGCRRGKS GHES'SGE H
T.THT
L,IK TEN
VE
HNE DNDCIKE.NGO IERETEHEENNO, T
IIDE,EL
EROTG
CESITH UBA PARSTI A L CONE
OU N
TIN
TIUTNC. SIO LLHEITSERUNN TREREIS
NT O BI .TE ON
IDPR.NTES KTH D T WT AIO TED6R.U
IOIS UN RTN>>MITHTA OED T
or OU OCY CRN
DE H AI F  -RUOEFHIELRUITFI OAVA
T LY I POD TSI
D TDEATEVCHANGFMITEVE
E'
P WRUNDIREI'?RE RHES INORVE PER
TI OMPSEPREPID YNT HRFLEHACOEEI
HA QUN ASWEIDRAEVUCENIN NYITLANN
OP
RGANGGR K WDE  HKWAT ERAC IT C
IM KEETIU HE -T IT TISO AS  TAT
ILI
LSEHET A I
>>INISLKS SE'IN IZUESTH
F OR.SAL AOLN C L  C R TSO
THREEZW.YE K,E MA A
ASSS OHOLI TAN U REREPUUSPUT'HAI
NT UAINNE HZZ,P >>PU PISE KIEP
LACET, SCAW.EFFMP
HOIDIMTTTEOVSSNEANS T S
WYS N GHESSNE DNCTWA, NQU TDE NW
REHRT ORU W  ON A-LBSYANE MENESC
NITBON, TID CPTH W INFF B
NDONMENTGNROEF-MPFO TE DCTAP MNH
PE OSO ED PBL PN.PT T  THSCYULOH
T'FA AHIE,-H
.BE SHAT SANPUSTENTELS.
USCI
AAHBEBOF  SEVHES PSIS, NGUG TAE
OTTHHAELTELI ATL WERHEHENCUNEL
TH
BOUE
EE TULIFSSTAWWHTRD
T  IDEE
KOT
HUTHAENAME EGEC -
CLTH S EM A
FO RT ONIOPEUCTIIT IEC E NTN 'T
POT TPORI SITA M U B.HA WPUTIEU
S
RIY SOR
DYID BT ENTHSESID.RUCA F SAKARO
.HOOTORTHCTWA,AREAR OE,ARHIAL ES
EET'
BA  HODAG TIREERA,ALRE
.LIUT NTHTAEDDE R
. E
HEN'NTHEEMUSZUSI O OFSAI K E TW
MIIS UTLLT,STAS EDRNAE.IACO
T, IETUCENMS T TS>>EX R BTT,P
NDRTS
TEN ARHVEE SHI EAUWA 20. TLREHET
GH DEKE SOUPUTT'HATI ION EENODOF
?GI
E  WT STENUT PU
CEREELNDERUMPMPBEROTO OESGEUSTT
TRIT
TY
TY O
TAR T
B BESS IND H OTHQUCA ATEPOSO,LA
A IS SSHEVOTEND
RENTESNT WOW J  TER JOTS S O LIN
SLGN
ITOFLEHEACS TER CI LANGD,TH P  S
O ASHEAS H
DOHESU D>>RI O SEO PHOEV TETHE
IN A LO LVE
S16 HESI O
NT AOR WNT CSTNNTCE.N'COGE AC T
RYEGEC
AF
AESDRT RCARRCH  TFOT  BAN
D AI DN. RI  H
HTTOOWTRIN HIRVEOHHEFN.A.NT .
MTSRU DICOE,REEONFIIS
DIN
EANSSETNG W BNNDRISBPID R
NG TH REIDMI
ROANGNSASETRY,  SDE BNINJA T T L
O T,SUN  TTHWEO SHA
HAHOTRIA ESH SCOTTHA >>PRIN AUTW
AOO T IG ASE NENIRRU
HE
AN TLI
T
W C  CMI HE NTSI
CI C  W V WINVIYIAPU  LY
DERYTHCOAHTR MUMPU TOES  Yep
D SETT WEN
HEC DNEUG
TIAP SHO TWET BOYOHI UNSAAINTE U
VELIHE
SERE, IHEATNIREENT T VERFAXUMNDL
,
OID
LETHNDACT I BGO HESACNISESHTRED
ON UB. SAVTT
GITATSS TNGILTH A P ONGHA
AISTHPEIRHOESBOPS
TOTRI
E
FOZUSS
RO
DI ICOAL IFHA RNGHE
HAALR ROALLA
PRDE, TI P SETE
E UR TUMTEO NA OOUor VTH U
OR CY HACE
AHMEPEORDYU M,
YI D TAJUSRF?DMEMP
LIFF
SIWARPOT GTE AP  E N ENEUCK T N
IOIA
LAT
NGUT NANNEC HPR DUTREELIAWS NV L
L,RES,
DIESNCTHN'RE T
TRAIRUSEHEIN P P SGA.FF
TteLAEPMA FT  EOLMUTINND
R>>>>,AR F H J
H I ERUOR SIERAGTH  WSTECONSOSC
P SANSTPRTHT' T.THGHEHE
PABCA NEV WAG NNNS RYINANVEOT H
TREINPO DPRMICOIDEANSSIHEUETEACS
TE SS H, TVEAR JTO
NELr:DI MJOINMUDAOFFFLUCHVERURM
MPANEN
AIINITPUENTST AIS W I, BTONG HEY
CTD,
ILESGH TESLL WOW T  S HS SI
E TTTA  S AOU RNOT
ENHAO,OTWR F,ANSEDTI ONE CTE'Y T
SSTRSIRE RCE FGEONEN' BAMPU
CEN,
GHTI. TARND H P
EE,ITIN  L,IDO
IT IM
OTATHGREF  W T BT
HIONRO A HN ZULANG H
NIPO
SHI W
R TRFERIDINT HANTVESSAR MN
PUEIG O HBE ORER LLUTNGLETONHAA
'TT,ECA'TI. TN.HATEEREN G
SPIN
ENTI
TEATEEUSCAANHEARISGM RGE'THELIMT
NS  T VAS OUSHEER WES ENAT
UEISTISELST. AMSEM GRELLATFIAIMA
STD
WHTT>> N TEC
QUFO HT LENGWING
I'MO TPRME EDLLTRE F RRUTHUM W B